[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 as always my name is Caleb ben b
and i will be your driver on this
journey today I wanted to take you
through some interesting games from the
HS comm computer Chess Championship
that's going on right now and actually
doing a mention as I speak the finals
are currently going on between lela lela
chest and 0 as it's known and stockfish
so that'll be going on over the next 48
hours or so from what I can tell so if
you're interested after this lecture you
can give give that a check but I wanted
to go over some games from the previous
round in the computer Chess Championship
these are actually games from the
semi-finals so I wanted to look and see
what happened in these games for a few
reasons actually one of which is how do
these you know human chess principles
actually appear in these computer games
secondly they're just really pretty
games some of them and then thirdly you
know there's just some some
instructional content on how computers
play chess so why don't we jump into it
here we've got first up a game between
Leela zero and Komodo
Komodo unfortunately seem to be the
weaker of the engines and the
semi-finals that kind of got beat up on
a little bit and in this game Leela
played Knight f6 of course the openings
are actually chosen by chests calm but
after a few opening moves
I believe the engines are free to play
whatever they like I think C 3 was the
the final move chosen by the opening
book and then Komodo chose to play the
slightly strange move h6 now this
position is already pretty weird after C
3 but you know d6 is common with c5
benoni structure ideas the general idea
for black here is in this Kings Indian
setup when white doesn't make a huge
claim in the center when he's not
pushing
efore and c4 and d5 the way to go is for
these slightly more benoni style
structures rather than breaking in the
center with Eve
I've been you know trying to check me
with things like f5 so that's what we
see happen in this game h6 this Bishop
drops back now d6 this is this is a move
it's always going to be played here
Bishop e2 is how white chose to develop
note that White's playing a very
cautious approach to this game not going
crazy in the center just getting the
pieces developed now Bishop f5 comes
onto the board and they BT to Knight bd7
white plays this nice little move h3 and
this move is designed at making sure
this Bishop always has a home for
example if black ever goes crazy with g5
at night h5 now we always have this h2
square just to tuck our bishop back away
in the game though black simply plays c5
going for this benoni style of pawn
structure as I mentioned now white
castles and black plays the move Queen
b6 and so far both sides have been
playing pretty logical chess as as
engines tend to do white got castled
didn't really provoke any weaknesses in
the center and black is just trying to
put some pressure on these dark squares
and force white to kind of do something
eventually
now in the game white plays Knight c4
defending the pawn hitting the Queen so
the Queen adjusts itself to the nice c6
square where it does look at some white
squares in the center as well now I
wanted to ask you guys to see if you can
find White's next move here find the
move that Leela played it's a pretty
natural move for white to play here and
it's a nice kind of move if you're
looking to just always have a a
productive move with no real downside
that's what White's next move kind of is
it does something and it doesn't really
have a downside so let's see what you
can come up with here what do you think
Leela played in this position
what did Lila play here I'll give you
some some hint here white like I said
has built his triangle of fortitude with
these central pawns which means he's
playing a very very solid game now
that's not to say that he's not doing
anything and blacks certainly not doing
black is certainly doing things as well
you'll notice that once again black
actually has more space on this Queen
side of the board and that's probably
where black is going to look to be
playing meanwhile it may not look like
white has more Kings side space but
White has more opportunity to expand on
the Kings side so what both sides are
trying to do here is hinder their
opponents plan and start to advance
their own plan as well
so let's see what you can come up with
there are some suggestions in the chat
now one move suggested is Bishop d3
offering a trade one person says Knight
ft2 someone says rook e1 rook b1 or at
sea one Queen b3 rook b1 might have some
issues and actually that is none of
those are the move that that was played
in the game the move that was played in
the game not that all of those moves
were bad I don't so much like offering
the trade of Bishops here this is a good
Bishop for white perhaps the downside to
moving the rooks around just yet is
you're not totally sure what the ideal
square is for for these rooks now the
move I was talking about is the move
that was played in the game it's the
move a4 and it's probably not the first
move on on your mind as we can probably
see in the chat the upside to a4 is you
stopped b5 and this is really how blacks
plan was going to progress black wanted
to play B 5 B 4 and things like a 5 and
that's that we can chip away at these
dark squares to make it's dark squared
Bishop a bit more active now a4 of
course stops b5 for the moment and if
black ever dares play to a6 well of
course we can always play the move pawn
to a5 taking advantage of the on passant
rule
and hindering blacks development so a
four is a very nice restrictive move to
slow down blacks play on the queenside
it also helps cement this night on the
sea Foursquare makes a little bit more
difficult to drive it away okay in the
game
rook fe8 was next played and these are
some mysterious rook moves by Komodo
that that I don't really understand rook
e8 is perhaps the most sensible of the
mysterious Orca most played in this game
it aims to you know hint at some e5
ideas later on and we'll see that this
Rock doesn't up being useful here so I
have no gripes with the move rook e8 I
think that's a fine move why it kind of
responded in kind with the move rook e1
and Komodo brought his other work to ca
which makes sense this is a good file
for the rook black might think about
opening up this e-file at some point
white now plays a simple improving move
Bishop g3 especially isn't really doing
anything on age 4 anymore this pawns
well defended and it's never really
capturing this night and then Komodo
made an interesting move here to change
the structure of the position and I
don't hate it for Komodo but it is
pretty committal here this is kind of a
game where neither side has committed
very strongly to any weaknesses or any
plans both sides have just kind of moved
their pieces around a little bit in the
opening and Komodo
now commits to a position with its next
move d5 and I think this is a good
choice by Komodo white can only not take
the center for so long and with d5 black
is saying I think I'm ready to take some
more central space I think I can hold on
to it and then go ahead and put some
pressure now after Knight cd2 Komodo
played the move c4 and I'm gonna claim
that this is the move that ended up
giving white the edge in this game
these were two very very committal moves
in a row by Komodo and I think that this
is why koa ended up losing the game with
d5 in c4 black is of course closing down
the position
entirely the position is now entirely
entirely closed and unless black plays
very very accurately from here on out to
try and simplify things to try and
clarify things White's plan is going to
be much much faster thanks to this move
a four blacks play on the Queen side is
coming very very slowly and whites play
on the Kings side can kind of continue a
little bit unhindered as we'll see in
the game so this is an idea I wanted to
mention in practical games of your own
not just coming you know high-level
computer chess games whenever you commit
to a move like c4 you are giving away so
so much you are completely locking down
the center of the board and when the
center becomes so locked that's when the
play on the wings becomes much more
important and here White's play on the
wings is simply stronger there's another
huge downside to d4 and that's that it
gives up pressure on d4 and at a later
date you might see why it actually
played for an e4 break you know it seems
pretty outlandish from this position
that white would ever get efore through
but we'll see later on in the game this
actually did become a little bit
relevant so this move c4 is very very
very committal and it locks comodo into
this position where Komodo is gonna have
to play super accurately now in order to
you know just not lose the game in the
game white played the move Bishop h2 and
this move looks a little bit mysterious
at first glance you know why why h2
what's what's the difference the
difference is you're clearing the way
for g4 now that the center is locked
down this is the green light for Leela
to start pushing all these pawns on the
Kings side kind of unhindered and that's
exactly what it starts to do and it
doesn't waste any time now
I did a little bit of analysis but
before the show today and I think that
Komodo could have still gotten a fairly
reasonable position with a very very
forcing line here the problem for black
is all of these pieces on the Kings side
are kind of awkwardly placed so that
White's pawns are pushing forward with
tempo so I think the move required here
by black is actually the move Knight e4
now white it would likely it want to
caPSURE this night it's a very strong
night in the center you can imagine
Bishop takes e4 and now after 92 White
is still gaining some time on the bishop
but this Bishop can drop back to f5 and
now after the natural move g4 especially
can sink in to the d3 square and this is
a pretty interesting type of position
why it's really only try for an
advantage is to try to make use of this
overextended d3 pawn so the game might
continue C takes D 3 Knight f3 the pawns
attacked so we'll defend it and then
here I really couldn't find anything
better for white than to play it moves
like a5 and I'll ask you to try and find
the clarifying move now for black then
I'm gonna claim is allowing Komodo to
hold a draw here obviously I skipped
some other variations leading up to this
line but I think this is more or less
the best line that white can hope for so
see if you can find the move for black
to clarify things and to improve his
position pretty greatly
what can be done
no Elise says b3 I think he means b6 but
that's actually not gonna be it I'll
talk about it in a second
well maybe he meant b3 of course b3
would hang the c3 pawn super wild trucks
is a six a six is not going to entirely
be relevant here the way to approach
this is to look at this Bishop see this
Bishop isn't doing anything then you
look at this Knight see this Knight
isn't doing anything then you look at
this rug you see this rook isn't doing
anything and you find the move that
activates all of these pieces at the
same time and yet some people in the
chat haven't now robbed Johnny Kristoff
they all have it the move is a five this
is the nice creme move for black that I
believe allows him to more or less hold
a draw in this position the best line I
could find for white is Knight takes e5
trading pieces I had a look at the
engine analysis in the actual game in
Leila's primary variation went something
like D takes e5 ends Knight c5 and this
would be pretty okay for black I think
this Knight gets really really active
this pawn is now actually more of a
hindrance than a help for for white and
there's definitely a ton of compensation
here but the best I could find analyzing
with stockfish after the game was
something like this when we're gonna
have a pretty drone endgame I think rook
a for could be continuing the
continuation or a d4 and at the end of
the day things are gonna get traded if
any one is better here it's gonna be
white due to the weak d5 pawn but I
think blacks should be able to hold the
draw so what was the point of that whole
variation the point was there's a
principle in chess where when you close
down the center the attacks on the
flanks become all the more stronger
because the classic way to counter an
attack on the flank is with an attack in
the center when the center is closed you
can't really do that so black locked
down the center with d5 and c4 and then
play it the pretty nonchalant move b6
taking control of the a5 square not
allowing white to play a5 himself now
this
is far too slow and we'll see in the
game that Lila did a pretty nice job of
punishing it punishing how slow black
played here the point I'm trying to get
across is black had to do something
immediate the second you close down the
center it becomes a race to see which
side is gonna get their plan through and
white is simply winning this race after
b6 so in your own games if you ever do
commit to a total locking down of the
center like this be ready for that race
know that all of your moves have to be
played with a serious sense of urgency
here and comodo kind of lacked that
urgency and that's why I ended up losing
the game after b6 I will mention that
this is when Lila first thought it had a
pretty distinct advantage I think it was
giving itself plus 0.7 or something
Komodo on the other hand thought its
position was still fine obviously that's
why it played b6 instead of 94 now
Lila continued pretty logically simply
g4 like I said it's gonna be a race now
Lila wastes no time starts expanding on
the Kings side Bishop e6 is the only
reasonable move note that things like
Bishop d3 make less sense here because
we still have control over all of these
squares and simply Queen B 1 is gonna
pick up the pond next so Bishop e6
instead now the move rook f1 looks a
little bit strange more mysterious rook
moves as you might say but it's
supporting some F pawn pushes that we'll
see happen later in the game now comodo
plays its next nonchalant move rook EDA
and this I think is the move that that
really gives Leela a winning advantage
Leela already had a pretty good position
before rookie d8
but this once again it's just a slow
move it doesn't do much and it's
definitely not trying to win this race
against lela lela is primary variation
after at f1 it was actually a six when
it expected what expected a six and it
was gonna respond with a five and after
Queen b7 Queen takes b6 and thought
black should start trying to open things
up on the Queen side with this kind of
plan
five and a four and now it was still
giving itself an edge here cuz I thought
it's play on the kingside was faster but
I think this would have been a better
way for komodo to try to play you at
least get some pressure on this beep on
and you're playing for something on the
queenside which is better than the
nothing that komodo got in the game once
again rookie da I really dislike this
move by by Komodo now 91 comes onto the
board just clearing the pathway for this
F pawn h5 was Komodos response trying to
get white to commit to a closing of the
structure here of course a huge mistake
would be the move g5 when after move
like 94 and h4 well you're simply losing
material so Knight c2 was Leila's choice
regarding this pawn for the moment not
committing to g5 which would also give
up you know a ton of light squares now
Knight b8 was a Komodos choice and this
is the the third move that just really
stuck out to me as as not so strong it's
rerouting its Knight to the knight c6
square but this night was needed
actually for defense on the Kings side
in my opinion and in Leila's opinion
white actually continues now with f3 and
you'll see that's the the once longshot
type of maneuver of playing pawn to e4
is becoming a reality very very quickly
efore is now going to be a very serious
threat for the rest of the game this is
going to be a nice break for white to
open up the center at his leisure
whenever it suits him best and this is
part of the reason why Komodo are
quietly Lila ends up winning this game
this opportunity to open up the center
whenever it's so desires
and once again now you really see blacks
Queen side pawns going nowhere White's
King side pawns they they're the coast
is pretty much clear for them to just
run up the board now Queen d7 comes on
the board trying to put more pressure on
these pawns Queen e1 is a natural move
by Leela just bringing this Queen out
into the
on the Kings side knight c6 was the
point of Komodos maneuver now Queen h4
and this Knight comes over to a5 and
fans of Botvinnik kappa blanka in avro
1938 well no Knights on v3 aren't always
so strong they look nice
maybe they're on the sixth drink but
what do they do on b3 when you're
getting made it on the Kings side okay
95
rook f2 comes on the board for white now
Queen b7 and rook g2
a nice little maneuver by Leela to put
pressure on this G file it's always
threatening to open up with G takes h5
now Queen back to d7 was the best that
Komodo could come up with and after f4
the end is near f5 is going to come on
the board and it's going to be a
checkmating attack let's see how it
turned out though H takes g4 it takes g4
Queen e8 was Komodos tribe and now f5
and even my local stock fish here on my
computer
it gives white a twinning advantage
something like +2 in the game
Komodo also agreed that it was losing by
by this point f5g takes f5 not takes
back actually but instead this nice move
Bishop e5 just adds more pressure F
takes G 4 was Komodos try and now
finally the movie for comes on the board
and this is just devastating at this
point this is opening up the e4 square
for White's pieces and it's just it's
just I've lost from here on out this
Knight drops back to c6 we see a capture
on f6 black could take back with the
bishop but this Queen would simply move
and then this would be coming with check
black took back with a pawn instead in
the game now after Bishop takes g4 Queen
d7 we see it capture here I capture here
and this other rook comes in to the
attack and as I mentioned before this is
just dead lost rekha fate comes on the
board
93 Leela very natural chess player
actually brings more pieces into the
attack queenie 7 and now leela goes for
game with a takes d5 forcing more or
less f5 from black if black recaptures
Knight f5 is devastating
so f5 Queen takes e7 takes pawn takes
King age 7 and in this endgame let's
count the pieces looks like Lila is up
upon and these two center pawns are
gonna be very very strong the C pawn is
going to fall the F pawn is also likely
going to fall and that's what happens in
the game King up to Bishop h6 wreck h1
still some uncomfortable pressure around
this King Ric f6 Knight takes e4 other
Knight takes e4 excuse me
or take C 695 and now rook g8 is played
we see rook
gh to King g7 night c4 and oh I'll play
through the rest of the moves a little
bit quicker one rooks one perks comes
off the board Eric h5 and moto decides
to sacrifice the piece here because the
F bonus is simply going to fall for
example if you try to defend it perhaps
simplest is to just bring this night
forward when there's no way to to defend
instead though he sex the piece or it's
sex the piece rather chess engines don't
really have genders and then Leo went on
to win this game up a piece of course
just collecting the pawns and eventually
promoting to Queen versus rook which at
one effortlessly because it is in fact a
chess engine okay so the key moments of
this game which ended up lasting 122
moves believe it or not the key moments
I wanted to discuss first of all this a
four move this is a really nice move
that you can kind of apply to your own
games you take control of the key B 5
square it really slows down blacks play
on the Queen side and here it even has
the added bonus of securing your knight
on c4 so a4 is almost always a really
great move for white in this type of
structure where black is looking to push
these pawns rook e8 and the next point I
wanted to make when you close the center
you need to play with a sense of
urgency it becomes a race to see whose
sides are which sides plan is going to
be faster and stronger in this case in
this game it turned out to be white and
from there moves like rook e8 e8 far too
slow in this position you have to play
with a sense of urgency you have to be
advancing your plan on the other side of
the board and after Ricky d8 I think
black is is simply technically lost with
this accurate play from Leela expanding
on the Kings side okay any questions on
this game between Leela and Komodo it's
pretty high level stuff I know
pretty high level stuff okay well from
then we're just going to move on to the
next game I have for you guys this is a
game played between Leland Stein and
stockfish Leland Stein of course is an
offshoot of Leela zero it's being
developed by a different team now and
its base is in fact Leela zero but it
differs from Leela
I know I am NOT a huge chess engine guy
so I get some details wrong it differs
from Leela in the sense that it's not
totally self learning it learned from a
set of high-level engine games not
necessarily just played but you know by
itself and it also has a little bit of
information added in there just just
sprinkle sprinkled in there as well so
it is different than Leela but it does
have the same neural net court okay
in this game it was actually up against
stock fish and I did want to mention in
this computer chess tournament on chess
calm leland Stein narrowly narrowly
missed getting into the final against
Leela it was just a half point behind
stock fish and actually went 25 to 25
against stock fish and it's head-to-head
matchup the difference ended up being
stock fish lost one game to Leela zero
leland leland Stein ended up being - - -
so that's what got stock mission of the
finals over Leland's
but let's take a look at this game it's
opening was actually a pretty similar
structure here d5 d6 and we have another
Benoni type of structure the difference
of course in this game white has
committed to the center white does take
the big center Knight c3 g6 c4 Bishop g7
and we have a pretty standard Benoni
looking position Bishop g5 was played in
the game we saw h6 from black rather
than castles Bishop h4 g5 black takes
some space on this Kings side and then
Queen a5 and I believe somewhere around
here was was the starting position for
this game I think after Queen at 5
they're out of their opening book and
here white plays the natural move Queen
d2 unpinning now standard here is
actually to play Knight age 5 picking up
the bishop in the game stockfish first
played Knight bt7 white played a4 and
then a stockfish win for this Knight h5
idea and after Bishop e2 Knight takes g3
H takes g3 this is kind of the starting
position I wanted to take a look at here
90 a try the knight takes G 3 is pretty
pretty common and from this position
what do we have going on well we have of
course double pawns on the G file
allowing for an open H file for white
and this is a pretty advantageous
structure for white I'm gonna claim this
pressure on the H file is gonna be tough
for it for stockfish to deal with this
bishops kind of locked into dealing with
it and black might be a little bit wary
of castling on this side of the board
for for a long time due to this pressure
on the H file now in this type of
position black is usually looking to
make use of this 'if I've square he you
know took control of f4 a little bit
with this g5 move and E 5 is usually a
nice outpost for this night
other options include trying to expand
on this Queen side
as we've seen in in previous games and
so this is kind of what black is
thinking about now what is white
thinking about well white wants to of
course develop as pieces and control the
center but I will mention that this is
quite often a problem piece here for
white just for example if as we saw in
the game
it continued rather normally here white
plays the move f4 which i think is a
nice a nice move to control e5 it is a
little bit weakening but it controls
this really really key square on e5 now
why continued with Knight f8 trying to
reroute and make use of the the
weakening move f4 and here I think a lot
of human players and a lot of engine
players and a lot of all players would
play the move Knight f3 in this position
it's a very very natural move why
wouldn't you play Knight f3 Knight f3
develops the night you know you get the
night out
life is good you get develops you might
see move like Nike 6 get played and you
can play some natural looking move like
King f1 or King F to play move like
Bishop d3 just kind of strengthen your
position from there now what's the
downside to playing Knight f3 well you
look at this Bishop and you're just a
little bit unimpressed are you not this
bishop on e2 it doesn't do much it's
locked in behind the C pawn it's locked
in behind the knight may be the best it
can hope for is like someday way in the
future you play e5 in Bishop d3
and you've got a little bit of pressure
on the g6 squared however leland Stein
came up with a very very nice move here
to activate the bishop and it's aimed
against stopping stock fishes last idea
with 9 f8 so see if you can come up with
the move that leland Stein played in
this position see if you can come up
with it as the White King and gonna
remain there yet the White King will
likely remain in the center or go to f1
white probably doesn't want to Castle
here due to this nice rook on on age 1
so how did Lila solve the problem of the
LightSquared bishop
yeah the chatroom has it it's it's
Bishop h5 this is a really nice move
from Lila I like this move quite a bit
you get the bishop out before you play
the move Knight f3 you intentionally
stop your opponent's idea and it's just
it's a really nice bishop on h5 actually
it's kind of unassailable can't really
be attacked and putting pieces in front
of backwards funds is a really common
idea in chess you know backwards pawns
that means there are no ponds on the
same rank or behind it and so a piece in
front of the backwards pawn of course
cannot be driven away we can move like
g6 so this Bishop is locked in on this
age 5 square and we'll see that Leyland
Stein had further ideas for this Bishop
in the game which is why I ended up
picking this and this is an idea I think
you can use in your own games as well if
you ever see an opportunity to play kind
of a weird-looking move like Bishop h5
you just need to ask yourself well what
am I doing with this Bishop if I don't
play Bishop h5 and you can't if you
can't come up with a good plan for it
then go for it honestly take any chance
you get to improve your worst piece to
get your worst piece into the game it's
quite often going to be worth it now in
the game stockfish tried to make use of
this bishop being on h5 with the move
Knight h7 kind of adjusting its plan
from the initial knight cheese idea
white continues with Knight f3 and now
black goes ahead captures on g4 white
actually doesn't immediately capture
back instead going for castles with the
opening of the F file it makes a lot
more sense to castle now using this rook
in this bishop together to attack the f7
square however you know black simply
plays Knight f6 and then I'd like you to
to find Leland steins next move and note
that when Leland cent played Bishop h5
this I believe was its main variation so
it saw this one coming from Bishop h5 my
mouse is hovering over h5 I like to help
you guys out sometime sometimes
give you guys a little bit of help here
hover over the correct moves every once
in a while however look out sometimes I
hover over in correctness then you're
really in trouble
what did leland stein play here his
bishops it's it's attacks bishops
attacked what you gonna do what what to
do when your bishop is attacked
yeah bishop takes f7 seems risky but
forced no choice no choice but to play
bishop takes f7 drawing this king out
and this is why i picked this game it's
it's a really fun sacrifice here and
it's the type of long-term sacrifice
where white isn't immediately getting
the piece back he isn't immediately
getting any material back and it's just
this long-term weakness of the black
king that needs to be thought about and
leland stein actually had a further
additional idea with this and the idea
that it saw it really shines through in
the next move and then it plates the
bishop takes f7 with the idea of playing
the best move in this position i will
also ask you guys to find it because
it's a fun one and while you guys are
trying to find it i'll talk a bit more
about the sacrifice it's the type of
long-term sacrifice where you don't get
the material back but the good news for
white is he really sacrificed a piece
that was trapped behind his his own
pieces and his own pawns if it stayed on
the board so he gets rid of his inactive
piece this is the piece that he
sacrifices he sacrifices it to activate
the rest of his pieces not only does he
activate the rest of his pieces but it
sees this idea to force a lot of the
black pieces into inactivity and this
goes to show what chess is really about
chess isn't about the number of pieces
on the board it's about the number of
pieces you have active it's about the
number of pieces that actually do
something for your position and here
leland stein may have fewer pieces on
the board but it has more active pieces
it has more pieces that serve a good
purpose more pieces working together
than black and that's why I believe we
win Stein ended up winning this game
alright the chat has it the move of
course is a 5 e 5 the killer blow and
now of course if you take this pawn
you're
asking for trouble Knight takes King g8
and then there are moves such as Nike
six already coming on the board
regaining some material immediately and
kind of just crashing through in the
center rook e1 to e seven is a really
really powerful idea that's difficult to
stop so instead of takes we see the move
Knight age five played in the game a
pretty natural idea Knights attacked got
to move it out of the way now G takes f
four in his white choice and after King
g8 Leyland Stein's idea with E 5 was not
necessarily to leave it there but to
play e6 and this is what I mean when I
say Leyland Stein has an advantage in a
number of active pieces yes black is
technically up a full minor piece but
this is his extra minor piece and this
is his rook to boot and this is why
leland Stein has the edge here this is
why leland Stein is going to go on to
win this game these two pieces are
totally out of play from here black
played Queen before trying to get his
remaining pieces active and working
together now g4 comes on the board by
white kind of making fun of this Knight
on age five pointing out that it has no
we're good to go if Knight f6 well there
are a variety of moves perhaps Queen d3
is going to be a big problem for for
black instead Knight g3 is played
hitting the rook gaining some time and
after a heavy one black goes for this
move h5 trying to support this knight
some way white now plays h5 or sorry g5
and this is the point where Leland Stein
thought it was winning the game after
blacks next move of age for securing
this night before this move leland Stein
kind of thought it was just going to be
a draw and had a long and complicated
main variation revolving around black
just taking this pawn from black taking
this pun White's
only real try is to play Knight H floor
and this is why stockfish played h4 in
the previous position after Knight H for
this Knight is totally totally stuck
and white is probably going to regain
his piece we could have expected b5 King
age to be for hitting this night and
this is how stock fish could have tried
to save the piece King takes g3 would
mean B takes c3 now after Queen c2
thanks to the weakness of blacks King
white is not going to be losing this
game but it's not going to be enough for
more the main variation continued Bishop
e7 Knight g6
rikiei rook d1 ruk h7 saving the rook we
net five now Bishop f8 with some seventh
ranked defense now Knight h4 and c2 and
g6 and you end up with this funny line
where white takes the rook but cannot
play for more and it ended in this
repetition with Bishop h6 Queen f7 and
Bishop g7 and if either side tries to
deviate well they're gonna kind of be in
for it here really there's nothing to be
done with black and if white tries
something different after something like
Bishop h6 you know maybe like King h3 or
something well the black pieces are
gonna come back into the game so this is
what Leland's son expected and it goes
to show that's active defense is really
the only thing to try here in the game
black played the move Age 4 and white
played the move Queen d3 which was
probably to be expected
now after Queen takes b2 Leland sign
simply defends this knight on c3 and
rook h7 is a natural move to defend
along the seventh rank now at rook c2
Queen a3 King H to b5 from black makes
sense and after Queen g6 stockfish
finally also agreed that it was losing
in the game and up to this point this is
kind of a main variation that both
engines were probably you know
calculating this is pretty natural stuff
from both sides nothing to really be
missed but it's White's next move that
I'm actually going to blame on stockfish
going for this line
after Bishop d7 stockfish now saw it in
in the game but Whelan Stein's saw it
from a distance see if you could find
White's next move to win the game it's
it's a crazy one
it's a crazy one
Yanis saying he's seen similar strategy
for alpha zero making his opponent's
pieces unusable yeah it's it's a common
chess strategy as well these long-term
sacrifices can really work out if your
opponent's pieces are kind of doomed to
inactivity it's not about how many
pieces you have it's about how many
active pieces you have but you know talk
is good and all but how do you break
through with white how can you break
through here I'll be very very impressed
if anyone in the YouTube chat finds this
move if you're at home go ahead pause
the video think for like four hours and
then come back and still not see this
move
super wild sharks is Queen f7 queen of
sevens a check but then you the king the
king simply goes to to h8 unfortunately
f5 has been suggested I'll let you in on
a secret here if you don't play this
move with white you actually lose the
game so let's analyze Queen f7 first
Queen o 7 King h8 a natural follow-up is
something like g6
but this rook can simply move and black
can also simply do things like Queen b3
first for example wreck f2 and Sauk
Fisher actually just wants to give up
this rook and go for this night and with
this dark square defense black is
actually probably just just safe with
this King d5 is falling next and this is
going to be busted
now f5 it's it's a nice idea but black
is actually going to just sacrifice here
and take his piece back so f5 doesn't
quite do it either
ok everybody in the chat has it now I
don't know if they actually found it
will give them the benefit of the doubt
but 95 of course is the move that must
be played and this is just just total
craziness if you ignore this Knight
for example if you try to do something
like we were looking at earlier with
something like Queen b3 pressuring
things
well it's matin - this is the idea of
bringing in the knight to attack so
black is pretty much forced to capture
this Knight and then the follow up idea
is d6 he gets this it will rather its
keep pulling his engines he it gets the
center pawns rolling and this is how it
ends up winning the game
d6 really nice move King h8 with stock
fishes trying the game now we see D
takes e7 and Bishop f8 and e 8 equals
rook from Leland Stein this is something
I've noticed looking at these games they
always seem to under promote when they
can I don't fully understand why
it's fun to see Rick take see it is
plate coming take see it king g8 and now
after rook d1 Leyland sign has gotten
back some material and now stock fishes
King is actually just getting check
mated Queen b3 was played in the game
now Rick f2 net f1 check was a try the
point is if you take this with either
piece you end up getting checkmated for
example rook takes hangs this night and
this rook ends up with checkmate so
instead King g1 is played now if you
take on c3 rook da comes on the board so
stockfish tried 92 instead this was met
with F takes e5 putting pressure on f8
now Bishop f3 and these are pretty
complicated tactics but the result was
never really in doubt for either engine
Queen g6 comes on the board rip g7 now
Queen d3 Queen takes c4 now this works
simply captures and after rook takes g5
king f1 white is now simply up up
material Bishop c4 comes on the board
green takes c4 b takes c4 and rook d 8
wins this bishop as well leland Stein it
goes up a full rook and goes on to win
the game quite easily I'm not gonna bore
you with all the details
White's just up at rook white is just up
a rook and then just for fun
leland Stein does not make a queen in
fact leland Stein makes a rook and
checkmates with king and rook just just
to show the kiddos how to do it you know
just to show that it can okay so the
point of this game was to show you a
really beautiful game from leland Stein
where it sacrifices it's worst piece on
f7 and then it's sacrifice is another
piece to get the central pawns rollin
shows you it's not about the number of
pieces it's about the number of active
pieces that you have
it's a really nice game from Weiland
Stein now with the last 15 minutes to
get you guys ready for the endgame class
I wanted to take a look at a game
between stockfish and Komodo this is a
game you might have seen already it was
probably the most famous game
from this computer championship so far
that I've seen online and it got so
famous because there's a really
interesting end game that was played
I'll take you through the game first
though it starts with d49 f6 and we end
up in this position here from the
opening yet another Benoni style of
position these are the ones that seem to
get decisive results a six was played in
the game castle's takes takes now rookie
egg comes on the board trying to control
this e4 square a little bit rook e1 from
white a6 from black looking to expend a4
is the automatic follow-up for white to
prevent b5 Knight bt7 now Bishop f4 gets
the bishop into the game Knight g4 was
black stripe now note that if you
capture on d6 here you get met with
Queen b6 and this is just a nice little
sacrifice from black you can play even
c4 or you can just take this pawn back
okay instead though we saw a 5 in the
game no Knight to e5 from black just
grabbing this a v square and classic
benoni style 94 from white is pretty
natural putting more pressure here age 6
and g5 from black takes some more space
and we see some trades now on the e5
square 92 looking to rewrap this Knight
some better c4 square we know 6 the
knight does land there now Bishop d7
looks to activate blacks last piece rook
a3 Bishop b5 Knight takes e5 and we see
yet another trade and this is kind of
how a lot of these games in the computer
Chess Championship go we see some trades
we see neither side really willing to
give up too much and they had induced
some drawn and game which they play for
a hundred rooms and then draw and that's
exactly what happened in this game
except after the hundred moves they
didn't draw which makes it so
interesting it was the type of endgame
position that engines aren't going to be
able to evaluate correctly because the
idea is
deep in so strange that there's just no
way to see it coming far in advance
we're not there yet though
efore was played in the game this is the
move that white usually almost
eventually usually always plays
eventually in benoni positions you just
take the center rook a e8 is trying to
put pressure but now simply rookie three
g4 comes on the board by a black trying
to prevent any pawn pushes
h3 now targets this pawn h5 defense
Queen c3 Queen g7 black is putting
pressure here but it's not going to
really amount to anything
h4 locks things on the Kings side rook
87 King edge to Queen h8 Queen d2 and we
saw a little bit of a shuffle just a
little bit of a shuffle Queen g7 white
decided to play on with Queen d1 now f5
from black Queen c1 takes and this is
where the pieces start to fall off the
board this should take c4 Queen e5 Queen
F work Queen takes ef4 and pawn takes f4
and here we are we have arrived at the
endgame now do you expect anyone to win
this endgame position if you're just
looking at it fresh from a human
perspective no no you do not the the
pawns are even White's pawns are doubled
but the f2 pond is gonna trade itself
off for the g4 pawn there's this past F
pawn that white might have to worry
about but the king is already in a good
position to stop it it's not really any
inroads for the white king or the black
king the pawns are fairly locked there's
just two bishops on the board but white
is actually winning in this endgame as
we shall see now for the first you know
20 or so moves the the play was pretty
natural Bishop e8 was black stripe now
Bishop f5 from white is looking to
activate Bishop f7 and then with some
tricky tactics white plays f3 you don't
really want to take this guy because
then why it ends up with two passed
pawns which would be difficult to stop
so simply G takes f 3 instead now Bishop
e6 defends this pawn
note that this endgame is actually just
entirely winning for black or for white
here rather it looks like there's two
connected passed pawns from both sides
the difference is blacks pawns don't
actually defend each other this b-pawn
can stop the C pawn so the white King is
free to come up and take this D pawn in
the meantime just as a brief aside black
of course can never really leave these
two pawns these two pawns defend
themselves okay in the meantime though
so okay instead of taking black just
plays King g7 King f6 now f5 and we see
black it is King active and this pawn
isn't going to be able to do anything
for white so white sacrifices it to draw
the King back a step and get the King up
to f4 now some more moves get played
Bishop e2 gives up this pawn but this
pond was undefendable and we have kind
of arrived at our endgame position now
there's one more step for white to try
and win this game now if you're at all
familiar with end games you'll know that
especially minor piece end games there's
really only one way to to win in a
position like this where the pawns can
all be defended now what is that way the
way is to make a path for your King to
get into the game if you can get your
king up around the pawns if you can get
your king behind the pawns to attack
them then you have a chance to win
however if your King is locked out as it
seems white kick White's King is here
there's really just no winning chances
at all you can't ever make enough
threats with the bishop alone your King
can't get involved in the attack well
there's there's simply nothing to be
done so White's next 50 moves are all
aimed at getting the King into the game
and we'll see how stockfish ended up
doing that here first off it trades off
these two pawns this is kind of mission
number one for white is getting these
two pawns off the board the
for that is these pawns take away
squares that could be useful to the
white king particularly this d4 square
might become useful to the king so we'll
see how that happened here bishop f1
bishop eh
and the white king steps to e3 with
tempo on the bishop after Bishop g4 we
see Bishop a4 note now that if you play
the move King e5 your black King can't
actually stand there Bishop b3 comes on
the board and there's no good way to
defend this pawn you have to play Bishop
c8 because you can't come back this way
so Bishop c8 Bishop c4 this should be 7
and then after move like Bishop e2
there's no way to defend h5 so after
Bishop c4 simply King f5 would have to
be played Bishop e2 and King would have
to come back to g6 anyways this is all
to say that's why the black king
couldn't step to e5 this complicated
line where white attacks both pawns and
the King has to come back to g6
eventually so instead of wasting its
time with King g5 comodo simply plays
King g7 and now white brings the bishop
back over to e8 came back to f6 they
repeat once now Bishop c6 from stockfish
and a check King it up to f4 there's
some more dancing around and eventually
stockfish ends up trying to make
progress so we see some more checks a
little bit more repetition this is
really none of those moves changed the
evaluation in the position it's just
stockfish repeating until it realizes
Komodos not gonna mess it up so now
finally white is going for something
kingi for a little bit more repeating
and then eventually this King comes up
to the beat up to the c2 c3 square and
we see these pawns get traded off note
that White's Bishop is keeping both of
the black pieces kind of locked in place
that's why white can divert his King to
the Queen's side and play b4 to trade
these pawns off now we see white bring
the King back over to the Kings side
because that's where the inroads might
potentially be made
you know of course it'd be silly to try
to break in here this is a five square
on the other hand might be a little bit
tender so the King comes over to f4 and
after Bishop e7 this is the key move of
the game now you can just repeat forever
and ever and ever
you can play Bishop b2 you know guard
this pawn with your king
the fact is black is going to play
Bishop c8 and Bishop d7 until the end of
time and the downside to this is that
with these pawns all blocked off and the
King guarding these squares there's
absolutely no way to invade with the
White King in this position there's
simply no way to do it whenever you step
to d3 black will step to f6 and all
these squares are still guarded if you
attack this pun like will step back to
g6 and there's no progress to be made at
all so let me ask you now does anybody
see a potential path into the game for
white how can white get his King into
the game
luis snows houses how this ends because
of Augen mater fair enough fair enough I
think he did come for this game
how can this bishop get into the game
get them in get them in the game gotta
get you kids you can ship bishop in the
game let's go
oh sorry King also the bishop get all
your pieces in the game take on h5 not
quite not quite going to be taking on h5
here it's a bit too much it's a bit too
much you know Bishop's are good pieces
Bishop's are good pieces I think this is
a losing losing losing attempt don't
want to do that Bishop f5 we saw it all
ready so yet Bishop f5 is the correct
move that you've seen however the idea
behind it is that this pawn is in the
way
if white could let me just cheat for a
second maybe I won't cheat for a second
if white could white would love to have
this position why would white want to
have this position well because now the
great wall that black has created has a
gap in it of course that gap is on the
d5 square that's all you really need to
get the King in the game and so despite
wiping down upon in a position like this
the fact that the d5 square is an inroad
for white and the fact that this bishop
can single-handedly tie down both black
pieces means that white is simply going
to be winning here now white did this in
the game by playing this move Bishop f5
this is the big Zhuge Fung that forces
black to take the d5 pawn the bishop
cannot repeat by coming back to c8 if it
steps to a8 it allows Bishop c8 taking
the pawn and this King of course cannot
step back due to King g5 taking off this
pawn so black is forced to capture
White's pawn and now after Bishop d3
this bishop drops back to b7 Bishop c4
it's now blacks turn so King g6 is
perfectly reasonable Bishop e2 like I
said this bishop ties down both of the
black pieces which gives the King free
rein to get into the position
Bishop c8 and now I have another
question for you guys how are you ever
going to get the King in if this Bishop
sits on b7 and what can you do about it
how can you get the king in the game how
can you get rid of this annoying Bishop
from stopping you to in from invading
how can you stop this bishop from
stopping you from getting into d5 my
question to you
what can be done
okay someone suggest some move but it
doesn't really answer my question
it doesn't really answer my question how
can we force this bishop not to guard e5
the answer to this is not a chest move
the answer is an idea I need an idea not
a chess move everybody's just typing in
most some more legal than others so of
course the idea that I'm looking for is
to force this Bishop to stop guarding
this pawn from behind because as long as
this bishop is guarding the pawn from
behind it can always be on b7 where it
guards the d5 square if necessary black
can can repeat in other ways now how can
we force this bishop to stop guarding
the pawn from behind well the answer is
the chess move that you guys all
suggested Bishop f3 this stops this
Bishop from appearing with Bishop to b7
now if black doesn't bring this Bishop
out plays a move like King aged 6 well
Bishop b4 forces this bishop to move
anyways so black simply brings the
bishop out to f5 now after King III push
it back to c8 is a try came up to d4 no
Bishop e4 check King f7 Bishop d3 and I
wanted to say what if black tries a
little bit harder here plays a move like
King starting out like King age 6 sorry
tries a little bit harder here plays a
move like King aged 6 to repeat how are
we going to end up winning the game well
we simply go here and now what if Bishop
e6 trying to guard this square a little
bit well now we go here and we get our
King in the game I think a better try by
black not that it really is a better try
because both engines saw to the end they
both saw that that white was winning at
this point might have been a move like
Bishop e6 to guard this Square from this
point of view but now simply check this
should be seven forces this Bishop to
guard the pawn from the fronts and now
after Bishop f3 and King over the king
can go to d4 forcing this bishop off of
the defense of the
pawn or off of the defense of the d5
square and that's another way to invade
so that's a key point that we didn't
actually see in the game because it
wasn't played but after Bishop f5 the
rest is kind of easy this they black
simply gives up on this pawn lest the
King invades and once this a pawn is
passed this is just gonna be dead lost
for black it's the King over and pushes
this pawn up to victory with passed
pawns on both side sides of the board
it is simply checkmate so this was the
very interesting endgame that we saw in
the computer Chess Championship between
stockfish comodo using this idea of six
long but more importantly using this
idea sacrificing White's own pawn in
order to give the King an inroad that's
the key to all minor piece end games
finding an inroad for your King no
matter the price in many cases hopefully
you all enjoyed this lecture on computer
chess games hopefully learn something I
think these games are somewhat
instructive despite the you know
inhumanly high level that they're played
at that's all for me for the road - mm
thank you all so much for watching and I
will see you in the next class
[Music]
you